all right i got rid of the hat so i no
longer have the evil vibe
oh okay i'm much more interesting on the
bat that's fast very good
okay i like that let's do it that's
something an imposter would do
by the way i'm not the imposter
number one crewmate any speed record
coming up yeah well
i don't want anyone to suspect me this
time because i changed my hat so
yeah you got a free pause now you no
longer look like it's a very nice hat
what are you doing up my juice
hi hello
you just click in the exclamation marks
it went from bad to fine uh-huh i'll
take it
that's the reviews i try to get in my
life really
i get sad when the lights turn off
because then i cannot see my friends
hey guys
did you just leave dodger
which one is it
oh it's you i'm sorry i keep scaring you
it's okay
it's okay no worries i'm not dead yet oh
you know i had to oh all
why have you guys buddied up well i
don't know because he
we didn't kill each other for a long
time okay
seems fine
i don't like any of that alliance
nope
okay
[Music]
every time i'm [ __ ] uploading to the
world wide web i was gonna say
if i've ever been so sure of anything i
was sure that it was not ross
because nobody had died yet and nothing
had been sabotaged
and now he's got a hard vote for ross
it really pains me to say this but
i crossed paths with mortimer
oh sweet no no no no that direction
she had the audacity to say i put bat
wings on my head to seem less suspicious
and then i rounded the corner and there
was a pie along to it
susie said i have chores to do again
we all know this
[Music]
i will say susie had a really easy
chance to kill me and she didn't take it
so i also thank you alone with ross on
vitals and now ross is dead
but i will say susie if you promise to
not
kill anyone i will not vote for you
that is true susie had a good
opportunity looked me right in the eyes
and that always works
of course he's right in the devil wings
could we now skip on nine this is like
this is outrageous classic skip one
night seems fine
we don't have any information i don't
even know who to vote for i don't even
know who you
are yeah see look at that oh we all skip
see this is great
yeah sue's immunity we call it yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
let me look at my map all right
[Laughter]
hmm
i mean i don't really know the map very
well
why do i have to go find you and you're
not just sticking with me bro well i
know i know
where are you
i have to do this this thing right here
i'm not gonna hurt you and nobody's
gonna kill me
nobody's gonna kill me how innocent i am
look at how innocent i am i'm not gonna
get mudded i'm just
downloading the thing i'm listening to
what simon says to me
thank you thank you okay what do you say
okay good day
good day
it's probably susie realistically quite
being honest
you know
just just get my [ __ ] tasks done
[ __ ]
hey dodger yeah hey
how you doing just hanging out doing
tasks yeah
that's cool yeah i'm trying to figure
out how this task
works oh sick oh it worked kite
i think that's the one with the sliding
thing yeah but every time i did this
lighty it was like please come back
yeah it's stupid you have to wait like a
set number of seconds
hey what's up hey what's up hello
hi hi everybody hi hey
hello how are you doing hakka i am good
i am going to make sure that our wi-fi
is so fast
hell yeah i finished all my tasks so
let's go
finals maybe sure you have mock show you
have i have
yes no no one's dead
so yeah that's stable back you got there
you're gonna be just fine i think
i'm gonna escalate you hakko thank you i
need to go finish the anomaly thing in
my bed
cool
well what just happened there
let's go okay this seems fine
i'm like almost done okay
i'm done with mine i don't know what you
do
i hope that ross is doing his toss
these murderers need to shake off the
people that are following them around
and get the killings that's true
why is everyone still alive yeah oh no
uh
i lost taco hey susie buddy
don't kill me i can't couldn't if i
tried couldn't if i tried
don't kill me come on
i'm not going to kill you don't worry
i'm people head princess
oh no oh hi hello
look see look
out suzy if
i think so too nobody's doing [ __ ] i'm
going i hope ross was doing his
toughness
i did i did my tasks yeah me too mine
are all done
where's cams or whatever where's that
where ross is always about
all right oh someone might be dead on
cams actually ross was on
or someone was on cams and now they're
empty
well i'm just gonna execute wow that's
my cue to leave
ah this is not going well nothing is
happening
i mean i think it's going great that's
true that's true
[Music]
okay i'm just gonna call a meeting just
for fun
yeah that's fun no problem
oh okay nothing has happened i just
thought that i would call you all here
today
to ask if everyone's up to date on their
tasks
uh yeah i've done all of mine i'm trying
to do mine but i'm too busy proving my
innocence
so who else is not all right all right
guys all right everybody
all right i have to be that guy i'm
sorry my love
you are the love of my life no no no no
no no no no no no
[Music]
couldn't make it happen and uh
it's not great that's not also did not
have a use
button
i think it was just a bug okay no one's
like everyone's hats keep disappearing
who knows what happened right right dan
have you done it
it didn't even walk bye guys why did you
all have to make me
live this life
that's fine
we'll just all go okay well if
everyone's gonna follow me
then i'm just gonna i think we should
all just stay here it's cold out
okay oh the lights what's going on
oh [ __ ] what does that mean
hello hello all right
i don't understand how we haven't won
the game who has toss left it doesn't
make sense
yes who has remaining tasks if you press
q it shows who has the last task about
really a what
yeah no it doesn't right no just hit q
i'm pressing it nothing's happening
really it works for me
where's susie
you're gonna kill me
security camera that we can eavesdrop on
their conversations
it wasn't me because i was with aaron
what the [ __ ] no that doesn't work that
way it was probably a while ago
yeah we don't know when it was killed oh
my god
i was very suspicious of dan and you
know now he's dead
actually i wasn't suspicious of him at
all i think i know who both
are but i just want you guys to go for
it you know have fun
just just [ __ ] around it's whatever
tasks are done
wait so who found the body um
a lot of people a bunch of us saw it on
the camera reported it
i have the megaphone on h
i we were all together this whole time i
don't know what to do
oh this is it's crazy guys i feel like
it's
all right this is horrible this is this
is like a real this is like how the game
should be they're just like i don't know
also i'm pretty sure ross is not doing
his tasks just to see if they can play
it out
ross could you do the toss that would be
really helpful for us we could finish
the game i think for us
[Music]
he said no in discord so
we can figure this out we can do this
who's got the last task goddammit who's
getting the left i think i'm done
[Laughter]
good
okay well if we all just stay here and
then aaron shows up dead it's susie
everyone stay in the room guys i'm just
trying to watch a movie
hey
he doesn't get impostor often better
just go check vitals real quick
well i still don't even know her see we
don't even know what's happening
okay it didn't work the other one is
right here with us either
yeah aaron's not dead lights are off i
can see the projector way better now
it's just movie night now i like this
should we just leave them off just like
for fun
yeah it's kind of nice yeah okay yeah
somebody could take an action doing
their tasks
it's not us that's right it's ross is
that long enough for it to be ross
i mean two people are dead but i didn't
like yeah but they're not dead
now i'm i'm not emotionally compromised
about their death so i'm fine
still nothing still nothing i don't
really have
syndrome on stockholm yet anyway yeah so
i say we all get a donut everybody
what if it's aaron and susie nah
i've been with aaron the whole that'd be
funny
but maybe that's what they want guys we
know who both of
do have to do this it's a huge bummer
making myself bait who is it who is it
who do you think the other one is i'm
not gonna say
i'm just gonna let them play it out okay
i wanna see if i'm right and if it's
right at the end but i get the moral
victory
right mark oh my god
oh that's crazy what is happening i
actually don't know how that happens
so weird i'm actually very scared
[Laughter]
i mean on the way there i told him i
would kill him but i didn't think he'd
actually die
wait so are you the predator no
why
[Laughter]
i really don't know look
i told him i'd kill him he's dead what
more can i say guys
does that mean you're the killer no are
you sure
i think it's time for me to die
i think it's time for spedice to die i
think it's time for me to die
oh the spa dicey again i don't think so
uh
he didn't do this wow wow well he just
said he did so what are we doing
he says otherwise a lot he just admitted
guilt no i think that he just doesn't
care
i don't think he did this at all i feel
like everyone how would he
he didn't get there in time what have we
become
oh my god he definitely didn't do that
jesus told me to vote how do you know
that it wasn't him though like
oh because i was within one of them
because we're still active
that does suck i mean yeah oh
[ __ ] i don't know all i know is that
hacker is clear
[ __ ] [ __ ] just rolling because i
don't trust anyone anymore i just want
to hide
jesus i'm so stressed aaron is it you
have you been killing me
wait what hey what the hell there we go
what are you not fixing
oh my god what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you guys i found a body yeah and it
wasn't me
okay okay i realize now that i hit the
button and it totally looks like it's me
but i did not kill jayden okay so then
it had to be dodged because
the rest of us were what no i was
literally you know
you guys doing lights because i know the
hacker and aaron went with us
but i'm so confused so
i'm pretty sure it's it's dodgy oh i was
with i was literally with you guys
in the group doing life scared maybe
because you didn't say anything
it's really confusing who have you guys
voted for who did you vote for hacker i
think it's dodger
i voted for roger my concern is now that
hacker has been playing me this whole
game and now i'm very scared
who did you vote aaron i voted dodger
i'm sorry
oh no you're all about it yeah i mean i
voted for that now
everybody won't be real scared oh no
look i think that it's done and i just
get to say i didn't have a say
oh no i don't know what to do this game
feels bad
i don't really like playing this game
look at this round of this game
i haven't played
aaron you [ __ ] sam
oh my god oh my god
oh my god i'm sorry
i'm sorry no it's all good
it was ross
and she was the only person who wasn't
doing it and i was like oh so
surely ross would do tasks while he was
no no i was you knew it was her because
you can remember
to see his body and you know she was
also never played this game
and you still let me convince you it was
me i refuse to kill you
i really appreciate that what is your
problem
there are only two hours it's okay i had
one hit on simon says and i wasn't
hitting it out of principle
because it was ridiculous i didn't do
the right thing you did the wrong thing
unbelievable oh you did the wrong thing
what are you talking about unbelievable
i don't understand why we voted sean out
that was really [ __ ] i don't
understand either i don't
understand either if you see me being
emotionally
my co-host aaron yeah i i saw the little
powwow you had with susie where you said
babe is it you and she said yes and then
every time she murdered someone and you
immediately said
what is happening
you made me want to say this i never saw
her do it though
i'm sorry dan that was awesome it was
actually that's
that's not on you this is all here you
guys know i'm capable of killing and
accusing my wife i've done it many times
i was genuinely confused on this one you
guys
right i could have just claimed that i
was it and then he didn't know
well that would have been easier to
swallow had you not stabbed me five
times in the head susie
that's a lot of times